We are on problem 18.
They give us an equation.
h of t is equal to c minus d
minus 4t, all of that squared.
At time equals 0, a ball was
thrown up from an initial
height of 6 feet.
Until the ball hit the ground,
its height in feet after t
seconds was given by the
function h above.
And c and d are positive
constants.
So they're telling us at
time 0 we're already
at height 6, right?
So h of 0, time 0, the
height is already 6.
If the ball reaches its maximum
height of 106 feet at
time 2.5, so h of 2.5 is equal
to 106, what is the height in
feet of the ball at
time t equals 1?
So we want to figure
out h of 1.
That's what they want to know.
So in order to figure out h of
1, we essentially have to
figure out what c and d are
going to be, right?
So how can we do that?
Well, we know what h of 0
is, so let's substitute.
So h of 0 gives us this.
Let's put t equals 0 here.
You get c minus d minus
4 times 0 squared.
And that is equal to 6.
And then if we simplify this,
this is, of course, 0, right?
So you get c minus d squared
is equal to 6.
Now the second equation, h
of 2.5 is equal to 106.
So that means that c minus d
minus-- what's 4 times 2.5?
4 times 2.5 is 10, right?
I put 2.5 in for t.
I just did that to save some
space. d minus 10 squared is
equal to 106.
And now if we want to multiply
this out just to see where
this takes us, because actually
I don't know where it
will, you get c minus-- I'll
put it in brackets because
it's going to be a long
expression-- multiplying this
out, you get d squared
minus 20d plus 100.
All that equals 106.
And then video. distribute the
negative signs, you get c
squared-- sorry, this isn't a
square, I don't know where I
got the squared from.
See what happens when
you take the SAT?
c minus d squared plus 20d minus
100-- I just distributed
the negative sign--
is equal to 106.
And then, let's see, we could
add 100 to both sides.
You get c minus d squared plus
20d is equal to 206.
I just added 100
to both sides.
So we're left with
two equations.
We're left with this: c minus
d squared is equal to 6.
And then we're left with this:
c minus d squared plus 20d d
is equal to 206.
And something should be
jumping out at you.
There's a c minus d squared
in both terms. c minus
d squared is 4.
Oh no, sorry, c minus d squared
is 6, the previous
equation tells us.
So we can substitute
6 right here.
So if you put 6 there, you got
6 plus 20d is equal to 206.
Subtract 6 from both sides.
20d is equal to 200.
d is equal to 10.
Now if we substitute d equals
10 back in to c minus d
squared, what do we have?
d is equal to 10, right?
So c minus 100 is equal to
6, or c is equal to 106.
And if you have an intuition
for how parabolas look, you
probably could've not guessed,
you probably
would have known that.
You would have known that c is
actually going to be the peak
point of this parabola.
And they tell us that the peak
point is at point 106.
And then you could've solved
for d from there.
But if you didn't have that
intuition, you could've just
chugged through the algebra
like we just did.
So we know c, we know d, so we
know the function is now h of
t is equal to 106, minus 10,
minus 4t, all of that squared.
And so we want to know what
happens when t equals 1, so h
of 1 is equal to 106, minus
10 minus 4 squared.
So that equals 106 minus 6
squared equals 106 minus 36,
which is equal to 70.
And we are done.
h of 1 is equal to 70, which
took us a little time, but it
was worth it.
I'll see you in the next